welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with something very very serious three
days of public mourning for Iran's most
powerful military commander are now
coming to an end and top Iranian
officials are warning the u.s. that
retaliation is coming general Kasim
Saleh Monte's casket was brought to his
hometown for burial this morning the
leader of Iran's Revolutionary Guard
told a huge crowd that areas supported
by the US would be set on fire a
stampede of mourners left dozens of
people dead iran's Foreign Minister told
our Elizabeth Palmer this morning that
the u.s. killing of Soleimani was a
quote cowardly terrorist operation
Elizabeth Palmer is in Tehran and joins
us this morning Elizabeth good morning
what do we know about how Iran my cousin
soleimani
is due to be buried today and the
official mourning period is over so
everybody is focusing on what comes next
and certainly any possible reprisal
attacks to ask about that i sat down
with iran's Foreign Minister Javad Zarif
who was denied a visa by the United
States to travel to New York this week
he'd wanted to attend meetings at the
United Nations can you confirm that you
were denied a visa to travel to speak at
the United Nations this week that's what
we were told by the secretary-general
that Secretary on Payoh called and said
they didn't have enough time to review
my request that's not unexpected but my
question is what are they afraid of at
Qasem Soleimani funeral in his home city
of Caramon in the south of iran there
was another frenzied outpouring of grief
and anger there were also more public
calls for reprisals against the United
States
Iran has powerful allies and proxies in
the region who could be used to carry
out revenge attacks but doctors are we
prepared to rule that out when I asked
him about reports that Iran's supreme
leader has ordered that any revenge
attacks should be proportional and
carried out by Iranian forces we are a
law-abiding nation when we take action
it won't be disproportionate unlike what
President rompers
there has been the killing of an Iranian
of several Iranian citizens and several
top ranking high-ranking Iranian
military officers that is what we will
do and we will do it not in a cowardly
way but in a clear and proportionately
well as we choose Elizabeth what else
did you learn from speaking with Zarif
this morning well he insisted that any
attacks would be on legitimate targets
and I really pressed him I said what do
you mean by that and he told me to go
and consult the law of war the Geneva
Convention legitimate targets are
defined as either military targets
specifically or infrastructure that
helps the military I think that's just
about all the answer we're gonna get at
this stage it does narrow it down
somewhat Elizabeth Palmer force in
Tehran Elizabeth thank you very much
you